uh let's do uh
let's do blake and mr keating shall we
don't go buy a book about terms of the
industry either i'll teach those to you
week by week we'll go through all those
terms
you need some help there buddy
i have bonnie gillespie's book it's
pretty good so far bonnie's one of the
only books about the industry that i
would highly recommend
self-management fractals yeah
it's really fabulous
and she's a very gracious giving human
being she gives away a lot of her time
and her energy
then you showed meisner's book the other
day i had read that one
i forgot what it was called
she's reading to find out what not to do
yeah i disagree
well he talks a lot about repetition
well that's what he based his whole
thing on and that's why my mentor and
coach charles conrad
broke away from sanford and came out
here and opened his own studio but
that's another story all good things of
all oh yeah
okay you guys ready camera's ready
who starts
uh i do okay
we're rolling
action
dad
what's wrong with grandma
she's real sick honey
is she going to die
everybody dies someday
i mean
is she going to die soon
son come here for a minute let's talk
i don't want to upset you but
yes
she is going to die soon
but
i don't want grandma to die
can't the doctors help her they've done
everything they could
for now
the best we can hope for
is for her to be comfortable
she didn't even know me earlier today
when you get old the body gets worn out
and things stop working the brain is
just one of them
but
i don't want
grandma to die i don't want her to die
either
she's my mother and nobody can ever
replace her
mom died and
little mickey died
how come everybody i love is dying dad
how come
all the good people in the world are
dying
i don't know
i guess god needs him in heaven to help
him
so what
why is god taking away all the people i
love what did i ever do to make him mad
you didn't make him mad you're a good
kid
and besides he hasn't taken everyone i'm
still here and i'm not leaving you
promise
i promise
mom promised she would never leave
either and she did
she lied
and you're lying too
you're gonna leave me just like
everybody else did not for a long
long time i promise
i'm going to stay here
and watch your kids grow up
i'm not
going to have any kids
that way they can't die
and cut lovely
good for you
that one actually hurts
of course it hurts it's a painful piece
of course it hurts it's supposed to if
it didn't hurt you wouldn't be human
see that's what's so wonderful about
this process that charles taught me and
that i teach you that's charles eric
conrad for those of you that don't know
he was not only my acting coach for 12
years but he was my friend and mentor
for 40.
and
that's why this process is so wonderful
because it allows you to experience the
pain
that you would be feeling if you're
actually going through the situation
you don't have to fabricate anything i'm
sorry what it was just this kid this
character lost his mother and his
i don't know who mickey is
it's his brother
mickey's his brother
so he lost his mother and his brother
and now he's losing his grandma
so you can allow yourself to feel a
little bit
more pain if you want to on this second
time okay
don't hold back
i want to compliment you not one upbring
tonight not one
not one good for you kiddo
you know we've been working on that
fine-tuning it they're all little things
we work on you all know i do not believe
in constructive criticism i think it's
an oxymoron i don't think you could
build something up and tear it down at
the same time but what we can do
is because we tape everything and we
look at everything and we see everything
and we send you free copies of
everything we shoot here
we can
evaluate
we can see what's working
what's not working
what you're hiding from us
see in theater and i love theater don't
anybody say i don't love theater i've
done theater my whole life
i love theater you can get away you can
cheat a little bit in theater
you can't cheat on film
film crawls in your eyes and in your
guts
counts the nose hairs in your nose
and
magnifies everything you do and feel
so you can't cheat
you know and that's what's so wonderful
about charles process
it allows you once you get your head in
the right space once you go from your
left brain which is the logical brain to
your right brain which is a creative
brain once you go there
it allows you to experience things on a
real
natural
personal level but you have to have the
willingness to go there
seeing a lot of people when they're new
here don't have that willingness
they don't want us to see them warts and
all
they want to smile through everything
or be tougher than everyone but that's
not the way life is
you know
pain agony and torture
is what life is i'm not a fatalist but i
am a realist
you know
so allow yourself to feel that pain
when we do this again see where john is
do you see where john's coming from as
as the
son of the woman who's your grandma
who's dying he tells you you say i don't
want grandma to die and he what does he
tell you he said he doesn't want to die
either why
that's his mom and nobody can ever
replace her yeah
yeah
pretty serious stuff isn't it yeah so
just feel it a little bit more okay
let yourself go there
just don't give a hoot you know what i
normally say but we're being taped
tonight so i have to be polite
you know i'm trying not to swear too
much
uh they could bleep it out
that's not the way i use the f word they
couldn't give you there
be
beep no so okay so we good in the booth
yep
okay
okay
dad what's wrong with grandma
she's real sick connie
is she going to die
everybody dies someday
i mean is she going to die soon
son come here a minute let's talk
now
i don't want to upset you
but yes
she is going to die soon
but i don't
want grandma to die
can't the doctors help her
they've done everything they could
now the best we can hope for is for her
to be comfortable
she didn't even know who i was earlier
today
when you get old
your body
breaks down
things stop working the brain is just
one of them
i don't
i don't want grandma to die
i don't want her to die either
she's my mother and nobody can ever
replace her
i can't believe this
mom died and
then little mickey died
how come everybody i love is dying how
come all the good people in the world
are dying dead
i don't know
i guess god needs him in heaven to help
him
but
why is god taking everybody away from me
what did i ever do to make him mad you
haven't done anything to make god mad
you're a good kid and besides he hasn't
taken everyone
i'm still here and i'm not leaving you
promise
i promise
mom promised you would never leave me
either
and she did
she
lied
and you're lying too
you're gonna leave me just like mom
didn't i just like little mickey did
not for a long long time i promise
i'm going to stay right here and watch
your kids grow up
i'm not going to have any kids
that way they can't die
and cut oh nice
really lovely
yeah good work good work blake
really good thank you yeah nice mr
keating thank you really super super
let's do uh
andrea
and bet you